biden can't remember where he is or what
he is doing but his white house is doing
an awful lot and the cdc deigns to allow
the vaccinated just a little bit
of freedom i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with the
vpni trust visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first the word is out people are
abandoning
they're overpriced wireless carriers and
flocking to pure talk for the same
coverage but at a fraction of the price
that's correct
if you're with verizon at t or t-mobile
switching to puretalk could save your
family over 800
a year and switching is super easy you
can keep your phone keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month which is a
hell of a deal and here's the thing if
you go over on the data they're not
going to charge you for it so you really
have nothing to lose
there's a reason pure talk is the
highest rated wireless company by
consumer affairs
stop giving your money to overpriced
wireless carriers and instead
start saving money from your cell phone
dial pal 250 say
ben shapiro and you will save 50 off
your first month that is pound two five
zero
say ben shapiro and get involved with
pure talk a lot of other wireless
carriers that really don't make clear
what exactly
you are buying they try to confuse you
when you ask them to describe the
billing plan and all that
not so with pure talk instead you know
exactly what you're getting unlimited
talk tech six gigs of data 30 bucks a
month and you go over on data they're
not going to charge you for it
right now dial pound 250 say ben shapiro
you say 50
off your first month pound two five zero
say ben shapiro to get involved with
pure talk
usa all righty so
joe biden is not with us joe biden has
not been with us for some time
and i remember back during the campaign
if you said this out loud people would
suggest that you were being
an ageist how could you possibly where
are the indicators that joe biden is not
with us
where are the indicators that joe biden
is falling apart that his health
is obviously not excellent upstairs that
that attic the lights are not all on
then not all the marbles
are there that he's now like toodles
from hook can't finish marbles
well i mean it's like right in front of
you guys
he ain't all there so yesterday joe
biden the president of the united states
god help us he was doing a speech and he
literally forgot
who the secretary of defense was and
also that he was at the pentagon
and also what is going on in the world
we have an inanimate object for
president of the united states and
honestly listen i made the case during
the campaign
and long before the campaign i mean as
early as 2017 the best candidate
democrats could run was an inanimate
object
because you put up an inanimate object
against trump and it becomes a
referendum
on trump and then the inanimate object
doesn't actually have to govern you just
put a bunch of old obama staffers around
him and they'll just govern
like obama would except with the
inanimate object as the front and here's
the thing about the inanimate object
he's non-threatening
nobody finds joe biden to be
particularly scary or threatening
mainly because your house plant is also
not scary or threatening
and has about the same level of
liveliness as joe biden
here was joe biden president house plant
yesterday
completely not i mean he does not know
what is going on around him it's amazing
just want to thank you both and i want
to thank the
the former general i keep calling him
general my
my the guy who runs that outfit over
there
uh i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
for all he's done to try to implement
what we've just talked about
hmm do you mean lloyd austin your
secretary of defense
and the thing over there is that is that
the pentagon the thing over there
you know where they were they you know
the thing
okay so we elected an inanimate object
and i get it
i do i understand a lot of americans
they're like you know what i'm tired of
all this hubbub i'm tired of all this
commotion i'm tired of the tweets
instead how about we just elect this
corpse this corpse that
is barely walking around and we'll
pretend like he's cool the media will
we'll put him in a car and let him drive
around like his weekend at bernie's and
it'll all be great and then he'll get in
and maybe things will relax but here's
the thing guys
here's the thing just because joe biden
is inanimate does not mean that his
administration is inanimate in fact he
is the most transformational dead person
i've ever seen in my life it's
incredible i mean if for a person who's
not actually
ambulatory at this point he's getting an
awful lot done and it's something to
wonder about
because what this means is that
effectively speaking the united states
has a caretaker government
right now the united states and this has
been true for quite a while the
president is basically a figurehead
you have a bunch of administrators who
actually do all the hard work there are
a bunch of people around the president
who actually do policy
and the president's job is just to be
the person who goes out there and says
things
that's pretty much it and nobody expects
the president to be a policy maker to to
compromise to actually shape policy
the president is just there for us to
see him he's sort of like the empath in
chief this is why biden is appealing
it's why he has a 60 approval rating
right now
because people look at biden and again
he's not threatening and he appears to
be
empathetic in the way that your
grandparents at the old age home
wants to hear about your life joe biden
wants to hear about your life and
meanwhile in the background all the
administrators are doing all the work
that you know completely shifts the
nature of the bound
between government and the individual
none of this is going to change by the
way this is the model
it's also one of the reasons why the
democratic party is actually kind of
reliant on biden
because the minute that biden goes away
and kamala harris a far
more a far more threatening politician
is in charge meaning that you can
actually see her radicalism my painting
biden is a radical is a difficult task
because biden doesn't appear to be
radical because again neither does this
cup
right i mean like things that are just
not moving and barely can speak
are not typically perceived to be
extremely threatening
but komalhara says things and laughs
crazily and is much more threatening to
the american public just in terms of
optics
not because of race and not because of
sex obviously just because as a
politician
she doesn't appear to be moderate in any
way which is why she was a complete
failure in the democratic primaries so
the democratic party is reliant
on the continuation of the trojan horse
the trojan horse is necessary
you need the face of the trojan horse
and they're gonna preserve joe biden as
long as they can here
they're not gonna they're gonna continue
to pretend that joe biden is with it and
and completely okay and the way they
will do this is by minimizing the amount
of time he spends in public they did
this during the campaign
the pandemic was a great help in this
biden was not expected to be on the
campaign trail
where he never had the risk of a bob
dole falling off a stage moment
he never had to risk the possibility of
hillary clinton collapsing into a car
instead he just sat in his basement for
six months
and did nothing and watched matlock and
became president of the united states
and that will be the plan for his
administration every so often they'll
wheel him out and he'll say a thing and
then he'll be wheeled right back down to
the white house basement
jen sackey basically said this she was
asked if joe biden is going to do press
conferences now
i remember when donald trump not doing
press conferences himself for
a long time this was considered bad form
now joe biden's like i'm never going to
talk to the press again or answer a
question
and in fact if i say so much as maybe
i'll answer questions
my own aides will cut off the feed they
literally did this last week we played
the clip
here's jen sackey saying i'm not sure
that joe biden's ever going to ask
answer questions again i mean joe
biden's just a figure in a wax museum at
this point
he has done about about 40 q a's
since he took office but in terms of a
formal press conference which i
understand there's a big focus on yes we
will have one before the end of the
month
and what does it mean going forward will
we see more of
president biden um specifically more
than 40 q
a's in the last month or where he will
be submitted to
more expensive questions follow-ups the
kind of things we're doing today
will will we see him regularly
i don't know that you'll see him more
than 40 times a month but i'll have to
tell i'm happy to ask him that question
okay now that is uh that is such a uh a
lie
by omission that he's done 40 q a's the
questions in these q and a's
are pre-screened very often they are
pre-screened by the white house press
corps i mean by by the white house press
secretary's office
this has been widely reported and when
when joe biden is being asked questions
there are no follow-ups
again this is all you must protect this
fragile mask
for a radical movement underneath
because what's happening in terms of
policy
is extremely radical very very radical
indeed
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that if you are living with any type of
chronic pain it is extremely annoying
so until i was about 30 i never thought
about this sort of stuff then once you
get 30
suddenly you're exercising and you just
get this nagging pain and it won't go
away
i'll tell you something i have been
using that is absolutely fantastic i'm
talking about cryo-free sport roll-on
developed by our friends
over at oh max omax's new sport
formulation includes
a deeply penetrating potent punch of 8.5
of fda-approved menthol levels to
instantly ice out and block pain
receptors reduce inflammation
improve muscle and joint flexibility the
best part this 100 natural remedy works
its magic within five minutes of
application
relief lasts up to eight hours much
longer than the over-the-counter stuff
you're going to immediately feel less
stiffness
more mobility omax health is offering my
listeners 20
off a full bottle of cryo-free sport
pain relief roll-on this discount also
applies toward any product site why just
go to ohmacshealth.com today
enter codebend that is oh max omax
health.com
enter code ben to get 20 off cryo-free
sport and site-wide
it's clinically tested it is
scientifically proven the product
reviews speak for themselves 95
five star reviews page after page of
customers saying they've tried
everything
simply roll it on where it hurts and ice
out the pain cryo free sport works
within five minutes
improves physical training recovery
performance go to omax health.com enter
code ben
get 20 off cryo freeze sport and site
wide
the product is the real deal i work out
a lot and i got to tell you i i hit the
omax a lot the cryo free sport is very
useful to me it will be to you as well
head on over to omaxhealth.com enter
code ben
get 20 off site wide okay so the
stimulus bill
that was just unleashed this 1.9
trillion dollar monstrosity that was
just unleashed by the federal government
is a radical shift in the nature of the
relationship between the government and
the individual
it involves a massive bailout to all of
the states and localities that have done
a horrible job
running their own business it has also
created essentially a brand new welfare
program
okay the welfare program rolls back well
for reform welfare reform in the 1990s
was designed to get people off the
welfare rules and encourage people to
work
and there's a lot of talk at the time
well this is going to create child
poverty it didn't create child poverty
all it did was push people back to work
well the new plan
from joe biden this stimulus bill
essentially creates a
a baseline universal basic income for
people
with kids now it is not connected to
work it is not connected to unemployment
it is not connected to anything it's a
new entitlement
okay and the way that you can tell it's
a new entitlement is the way the media
are talking about it's supposed to
sunset next year
but republicans are then going to be in
the position of saying okay it needs to
go away
and democrats know this which is why
they passed it in the first place
the new york times calls it a policy
revolution in aid for children
according to jason deparle a year ago
anik hope a single mother in suburban
atlanta was working as a letter carrier
running a side business catering picnics
and settling into a rent to own home in
stone mountain georgia where she thought
her boys would flourish in class and
excel on the football field
then the pandemic closed the schools the
boy's grades collapsed with distance
learning
should quit work to stay home in hopes
of breaking their fall unexpected
unemployment aid expecting unemployment
aid that never came she lost her
utilities ran short on food was
recovering from an immobilizing bout of
covet when a knock brought marshalls
with eviction papers
depending on when the snapshot is stated
miss hope might appear as a striving
emblem of upward morbidity or a mother
on the verge of homelessness but in
either guys she's among the people
democrats seek to help
with a mold breaking plan on the verge
of congressional passage to provide most
parents a monthly check
of up to 300 per child obscured by other
parts of president biden's 1.9
trillion stimulus package the child
benefit has the makings of a policy
revolution see this is the thing there's
a lot in there
okay it is not just that people who are
unemployed get checks
that would make some sense right if
you're talking about the government
forcing people into unemployment lines
then the government compensating them
for forcing them into unemployment lines
makes some sense
that is a taking when the government
takes your job the government has to
compensate you for the taking of your
job
okay but what we are talking about now
is setting up what is effectively a
permanent
welfare program though framed in
technocratic terms as an expansion
of as an expansion of an existing tax
credit it's essentially a guaranteed
income for families with kids akin to
children's allowances that are common
in other rich countries it's just like
europe so that means it's good
the basic idea here is that the child
tax credit which used to be applied
against the taxes you paid right that's
why it's called a tax credit
if you didn't pay taxes you didn't get
the child tax credit well now it doesn't
matter whether you pay taxes you still
get what we're going to lie about and
call it tax credit it's not a tax credit
because you're not paying taxes
it's just a redistribution check the
plan establishes the benefit for a
single year but if it becomes permanent
says the new york times as democrats
intend it will greatly enlarge the
safety net for the poor and the middle
class at a time when the volatile modern
economy often leaves families moving
between those groups
more than 93 percent of children 69
million would receive benefits under the
plan at a one-year cost
of more than 100 billion dollars it
raises the maximum benefit most families
will receive by up to 80
per child extends it to millions of
families whose earnings are currently
too low to qualify under existing law
because again
it was a child tax credit so they're
just backdooring right they're saying
this is not a ch
it's it's not a child tax credit anymore
now it is a check now
one of the things that the government
did in the 1960s is they dramatically
increased the single motherhood rate
in both the black and the white
communities in the in in
1960 the black single motherhood rate
was 20 today it's in excess of 70
in the white community the white single
motherhood rate was somewhere on the
order of five percent today it's in
excess of 40
that is specifically because of welfare
policies that incentivize people to have
kids and not have a husband in the home
because if the income got too high you
didn't get that you didn't get the
credit from the welfare program
this is not quite that but the
similarities are pretty stunning
while the current program distributes
money annually as a tax reduction to
families with income tax liability
or a check to those to puerto o income
taxes the new program would set both
groups monthly checks to provide a more
stable
cash flow by the standards of previous
days debate of previous aid debates
opposition has been surprisingly muted
the bill hasn't won any republican
votes but critics have focused on other
elements of the rescue package some
conservatives call the child benefit
welfare and warn that it's going to bust
budgets and weaken incentives to work or
to marry
which of course is correct when the
government becomes apparent and
essentially is footing all your bills
then your incentive to
actually create an upwardly mobile
family unit is greatly lessened
we you see less income mobility less
family formation less
productive i would say less productive
trajectory for children
in a situation in which the government
plays father it's a problem
okay but democrats are pushing that
forward so it's a reversion back to 1960
standards
of how the war on poverty was to be
fought by the way we have now spent 22
trillion dollars in the war on poverty
over the course of the war in poverty
and we have not budged the percentage of
people who are living below the poverty
line in the united states
pretty much at all the economic shock
and racial protest of the past year
brought new momentum
to the plans as the new york times whose
reach while broad would especially help
black and latino families who are
crucial to the democrats coalition
okay so in other words it's a
specialized giveaway to a particular
voting block that biden wants to help
out
mr biden's embrace of the subsidies is a
leftward shift for a democratic party
that made deep cuts in cachet in the 90s
under the theme of ending welfare as a
senator biden supported the 1996 welfare
restrictions
as recently as august his campaign was
non-committal about the child benefit
now
the president promotes projections that
the monthly checks up to 300 bucks for
young children and 250 bucks for those
over
five would cut poverty by 45 for
children and by more than 50
among black families okay so here's the
question is that true
because we've had these sorts of
benefits before it has not cut poverty
it turns out that you can sign checks to
these families and that doesn't mean
that poverty is going to be cut
in the end because in order to get out
of poverty you actually have to make a
series of decisions that get you out of
poverty over time
it is not merely a question of signing
people checks if it were merely a
question of signing people checks again
22 trillion dollars spent over the last
60 years in the united states would have
been a pretty good way to alleviate
poverty it has not alleviated poverty
in the united states in fact the black
middle class was growing faster in the
1950s than it has
after that thanks largely to the
intervention of the federal government
in welfare
programs like this but again this is the
kind of policy that joe biden is now
pushing
or at least his administration is while
he's asleep on the couch
or at the denny's for the early bird
dinner
so that is a major policy shift for
biden and of course he's going to be
championing that tonight he's going to
deliver a prime time address
on thursday actually marking the first
anniversary of the virus restrictions
and he's going to champion his own role
in overcoming the virus
now here's the thing his own role in
overcoming the virus has been pretty
limited
and you want an indicator of just what
joe biden has done on a personal level
there was supposed to be a hundred mass
vaccination sites set up by the federal
government by the end of february by the
end of february there were seven
and the these systems were in place it
is governors who have been doing the
heavy lifting here all the federal
government could do
was help actually obtain the vaccines
and the dosages any federal government
worth at salt
would have done all of that but you're
going to see a a
victory lap here by joe biden and again
this is a heady time because we're
spending all the money and that's fine
we're going to spend all the money and
it's going to be all be great because
we're going to spend all the money we
did this in the 60s
okay in the 1960s we blew out the
spending if you look at the growth rates
in the early 60s and gdp and the
american economy very very high
that was because the rest of the world
had been devastated by world war ii
they were still trying to move beyond
their own socialistic policies many
many of them had to curb them those
policies in the 1960s the united states
decided it was going to become
a social democratic country it's going
to become much more european
in its view of the welfare state we blew
out the domestic spending we actually
blew out military spending as well for a
period there
and we ended up with the stagnation of
the 1970s an awful time for economics so
bad that there was a backlash in the
form of the reagan revolution in the
1980s
so that is what we are about to relive
we're basically just reliving
the mid-1960s to late 1970s
and this began over the course of the
past couple of years
with the with the pandemic it began with
the with the
racial protests and riots in america's
major cities
it feels very much like about 1968 right
now
it feels a lot like that in terms of
where we are and what the next decade
is going to look like and of course joe
biden is in on it meaning he's loving
this stuff
and it's not just joe biden's stimulus
plan that is a major move joe biden is
also moving to kill due process
on college campuses so one of the good
moves by the trump administration
secretary of education betsy devos had
put in place due process rules on
college campuses if
a guy if a man a young man was accused
of sexual assault
he actually had to process on his
college campus he had the right to face
his accuser
he had the ability to actually bring
evidence to defend himself joe biden is
going to roll all of that back
so we're going to go back to the
kangaroo courts that were that were the
the presumptive rule under barack obama
or if somebody accused you that was
tantamount to guilt
and now you could be expelled from
campus
according to the new york times
president biden on monday directed the
education department to conduct an
expansive review
of all policies on sex and gender
discrimination and violence in schools
effectively beginning his promised
effort to dismantle trump era rules on
sexual misconduct that afforded greater
protections to students
accused of assault now we used to
believe in this country in due process
of law
on college campuses due process of law
does not apply democrats don't want it
to apply and now they're actually
mandating under title ix
that due process not apply with two
executive orders one ordering the new
education secretary to review the
policies the other establishing a
gender-focused white house policy
council
mr biden and author of the violence
against women act waded into an area
that has been important to him but has
been politically charged for more than a
decade
the obama administration issued guidance
to schools colleges and universities
that critics in and out of academia had
leaned too heavily toward accusers and
offered scam protections or due process
for students and faculty accused of
sexual harassment assault or other
misconduct
the trump administration swept those
aside delivered the first ever
regulations on sexual misconduct
it is unclear whether biden's review of
all policies under title
ix a 1972 law prohibiting sex-based
discrimination
and federally funded schools will return
to the obama administration's approach
or find some middle ground
um they're not making it clear but it's
going to go back to the obama approach
because remember this is just obama's
third term by name sentient
okay everybody around him is an obama
holdover every single person
everyone around him is an obama holdover
this is obama's third term
so we are going to return to the bad old
days when anybody
who was accused of a sexual harassment
or sexual assault
receives no due process on college
campuses
jennifer klein is leading the
re-established white house gender policy
council with
julissa reynoso the chief of staff to
joe biden she told reporters on monday
everybody involved in a sexual complaint
accused an accuser was entitled to due
process but that's not right okay that
is not what they believe
instead what they believe is that sexual
harassment should be broadly defined
there should be no cross-examination
and schools don't have to find beyond a
reasonable doubt or even beyond
preponderance of the evidence basically
a claim
is tantamount to guilt that is what we
are going back to that is a major shift
in policy
okay meanwhile the biden administration
continues to push forward the idea that
men are women and women are men we have
a gender policy council
in which the rights of women are
supposed to be upheld by declaring that
men
can be women which is super exciting
stuff
jen sackey is now saying that for biden
boys racing against girls in sports
that's a human right
this is the white house press secretary
the president's position
on the rights of transgender kids to
play sports is clear he signs an
executive order
uh and he believes transgender rights
are human rights
and wants to see kids have the
opportunity to
play sports and participate in a range
of activities so it is a human right
for boys to participate in sports
against girls so long as they believe
that they're girls
that is a human right these are major
policy shifts because remember
when they say that that's a human right
what they also mean is that if a boy
identifies as a girl in your house and
that boy goes to school to a public
school that the school should be allowed
to prescribe
puberty blockers to the kid without your
permission we know this because the
deputy
secretary of health and human services
dr rachel levine
has said as much to roger severino
former staffer at the trump
administration
okay this is this is madness but this is
going to be federal policy
this is a transformational presidency
under the guise of a dead person
under the guise of a person who is not
with us that of course
is the entire draw there is something
quite perverse by the way about the
gender policy council
in favor of women suggesting that men
can be women sort of undercuts the
generalized point you would think but
apparently not
in just a second we'll get to more of
this first let's talk about your sleep
quality so
i will admit to you my kids are just
killing me my kid
so my baby she is uh we are getting her
off the pacifier which means that she's
been getting up for an hour every night
and screaming
and then this morning my kids decided it
would be fun to get up at five o'clock
in the morning for no reason
at all well this is one reason that i
treasure the moments when i actually can
sleep and in order for me to sleep
properly i need
my pillow my pillow products they don't
go flat you can wash and dry them as
many times as you want they maintain
their shape best of all
they are made right here in the united
states if you don't have a my pillow or
you know somebody who does it now is the
time to get one
because for a limited time my pillow is
offering their premium my pillows for
their lowest price ever you get a queen
size premium my pillow regularly 69.98
for just 29.98 that is 40 bucks in
savings kings
are only five dollars more folks now is
a great time to buy not only are you
getting the lowest price ever they are
the best gifts ever 29.98 for a queen
size
premium my pillow head on over to
mypillow.com click on that radio
listener square there you will find not
only this amazing offer but also deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including the keys of dream bed sheeps
the my pillow mattress topper and my
pillow towel sets or
call 800 651 1148 use promo code daily
wire that's 800 651
1148 go check them out right now okay so
the radical shifts in policy that are
taking place under the biden
administration
are indeed quite radical and we're all
supposed to ignore this because biden
has cute dogs by the way
side note on joe biden's dogs apparently
those cute doggies though
you know like he slipped in the shower
and he hurt his foot and because he was
chasing his dog naked around
like again this is the president and
we've had it's been a
wild ride here the past few years i
gotta say this is
like having a um having
a guy who chases his dog around the
bathroom
naked to grab its tail and breaks his
foot
and then can't remember anyone who is
around him
we're either living in the in the
world's darkest sitcom or the world's
funniest tragedy
i'm not really sure which in any case
worth noting the two german shepherds
belonging to president biden and first
lady jill biden
i can't wait hold on dr joe biden cnn
cut that crap right now
we'll return to the biden family home in
delaware last week after aggressive
behavior at the white house
involving major biden major was adopted
by biden in november 2018 from a
delaware animal shelter had what one of
the people described as a biting
incident with a member of white house
security
the exact condition of the victim is
unknown but the episode was serious
enough the dogs were subsequently moved
to wilmington delaware where they remain
ah man i can't believe they're this
cruel to the dog i mean i have the
cruelty to animals here
i remember when mitt romney strapped a
dog to the top of his car it was a
presidential story
i remember when ted cruz left his dogs
in the care of an actual dog sitter
well he was in cancun mexico and that
was him being cruel to the dog here you
have biting incidents and the dog's
being sent back home to delaware but
it's okay because after all
you know it's joe biden so who cares i
mean he likes ice cream
meanwhile the policy gets more and more
radical jen cline the head of the white
house gender policy
council because this is what we do now
we just divvy up americans
by immutable characteristic and then we
decide
how reality should conform to the
demands of the wokest among us
she says maybe we should add a third
gender to federal forms
yeah that'll be clarifying that makes
perfect sense actually i have a question
why a third
i've been informed that there are 57
genders frankly according to the
description of gender theorists i don't
understand why there aren't infinite
genders
if gender is a complete spectrum that
means that you should be able to name
you should be able to change and name
your gender at any time of any day
and since we no longer care about
objectively verifiable data why a third
gender why not like
a million genders i mean if you want to
identify as an attack helicopter today
you should be able to do so and i
believe you should be able to do so on
federal forms
frankly i find this this whole
conversation pan-phobic
we are we are now phobia we are phobic
of people who are pangender
and or we are phobic of actual metal
hardware pans that you cook eggs in
one of those two things anyway here's
jen klein from the rostrum of the white
house press
room yesterday saying maybe we should
add more genders to federal forms yes
this is definitely going to help things
the president and the vice president
campaign during the election
on giving a third gender option
on federal government ids to individuals
who want them
does the president see value and sign an
executive order to make that
happen
i haven't looked yet to see whether that
requires an executive order
i mean i would note that we are um very
inclusive in our definition of gender
um and we intend to address all sorts of
discrimination and you know fight for
equal white rights for
um people whether that's lgbtq plus
people women
girls uh men um
so you know that's certainly um
something that we will look at
okay you're not gonna fight for the
rights of men unless you're fighting for
the right of a man to identify as a
woman then i assume that you'll
fight for that in contravention to the
needs of women by the way it is
incredible how lgbtq plus
has become just a giant phrase that we
all say together and the reality is
there are
significant internal distinctions
between each one of these groups
in terms of the view of sex and gender
it is very difficult to make the case
for lesbian and gay which
which are fully reliant on the idea that
there are distinctions that matter
between the two sexes
and transgender which assumes that all s
all distinctions between
the sexes are completely arbitrary and
there's an ideological distinction there
that is completely glossed over in the
desire to tear down
fundamental institutions of our society
because all that matters is tearing down
the institutions
i tweeted yesterday that we don't have
in the united states a culture and a
counterculture what we just have is an
anti-culture we have an entire political
and media culture designed to to just
destroy old institutions it is not about
building anything new
it is not about creating some sort of
alternative is about just destroying
what is there that's all this is and
when you're talking
about nonsensical stuff the way that
people are talking about nonsensical
stuff
uh that that can only be seen as a sort
of deconstructionist attempt to get rid
of institutions
which is what jen klein is is talking
about right there meanwhile joe biden
pushing radical immigration policy as
well his immigration policy is pretty
obvious
open the borders and let everybody come
this has some pretty dire side effects
by the way
but even new york times reporters at
this point are acknowledging that
migrants are showing up on mass on the
southern border specifically because of
joe biden
i was actually just at the border and
some of the families i spoke to
who had recently arrived did say
that another reason is the transition to
a new administration
they perceive president biden who
campaigned on a more
compassionate approach to the border
than his predecessor
as potentially being more lenient at the
border
so um yes i mean that's perfectly
obvious by the way the unintended side
effect of this is that wait for it wait
for it wait for it joe biden is keeping
kids in cages
now i'm old enough to remember because
again i'm more than three years old i'm
old enough to remember
when having to house kids in temporary
detainment facilities
was considered nazi-esque right donald
trump was a nazi this was nazi germany
america
well now we know that kids are being hap
they are being held in cages
literal cages okay the new york times
reporting a surge in migrant children
detained at border is straining shelters
quote
the number of unaccompanied migrant
children detained along the southern
border has tripled
in the last two weeks to more than 30 3
filling facilities akin to jails i love
how they say this right
facilities akin to jails what let me
call a facility akin to
a jail what is is there is there could
we look to the thesaurus please
facility akin to a jail
oh you're talking about kids in cages
that's what you mean that's what you
mean new york times
as the biden administration struggles to
find room for them in shelters according
to documents obtained by the new york
times
more than 1 360 of the children have
been detained
beyond the 72 hours permitted by law
before a child must be transferred to a
shelter according to one of the
documents
dated march 5th you mean we have over a
thousand children who are being held in
cages
in defiance of federal law because you
don't have the resources
you know who else did this had a little
mustache spoke german
yep yep you know what i'm talking about
the figures
highlight the growing pressure on
president biden to address the increased
number of people trying to cross the
border in the belief
he will be more welcoming to them than
former president donald j trump was yes
even the new york times is acknowledging
that this is all about joe biden saying
we are going to let everybody in
when you tell everybody that you're
going to let them in and just give them
asylum and they're going to release them
into the interior what the hell do you
think is going to happen these are
radical policies
policy shifts guys we're going back to
the welfare policies of the 1960s we're
going back to the immigration
policies essentially of of
of amnesty like full-scale amnesty come
to the border and we will let you in
and we are going to the gender power
going to gender policies that are so
radical
that they would have been beyond the
radical feminists of the 1990s that is
that is where we have gone
and all of this is being done as a non
as a non-functional member of the of the
upper echelon of american politics
stumbles around into objects
and chases after his dog naked that is
what we are as a society that is what we
have become
a non-sentient person is now running
administration
he he ain't running it right it runs
itself
it runs itself because all we do every
four years is just elect
the team of administrators who are going
to dictate our lives meanwhile other
transformational changes
there the democrats are pushing forward
hr one we've discussed this on the
program before this is a radical shift
how voting is going to be done in the
country now remember
according to the democrats there was no
voter fraud and no voter irregularity in
the last election cycle
it was the cleanest election in american
history according to democrats
and that's why it resulted in a joe
biden win because it was such a clean
election
well now democrats are claiming we need
a massive overhaul
of every voting system in the united
states which is weird since if you guys
are so concerned about voter fraud and
regularity
why exactly are you doing this hr one is
not merely
a vote broadening procedure hr one is a
complete overthrow of the federalist
structure with regard to voting
and is in an attempt it is an attempt to
backfill american voting law
so as to make it easier for people to
commit voter fraud and regularity that's
what hr one is
that is being pushed by the biden
administration as well we'll get to that
in just one moment
first let us talk about the fact that
you know if you're a dude
at a certain point in your life probably
gonna start losing your hair and it's
earlier than you think you think oh well
my dad lost his hair in his 40s wrong he
started losing in his 30s if you're not
thinking about it right now
you're missing out because once that
hair is gone very difficult to bring
back
this is why you need the help of the
folks over at hymns
hymns is helping dudes be the best
version of themselves with licensed
medical providers and fda approved
products to help treat hair loss
no snake oil pills no gas station
counter supplements hymns
was created by a dude who knows some
men's health conversations are easier
online
than in person no more awkward in-person
doctors visits or long pharmacy lines
four hymns connects you to licensed
medical professionals online that could
save you hours it's completely
confidential it is discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review and if they
determine it's right for you they can
prescribe you medication to treat hair
loss that is shipped directly
to your door today hymns is giving you
their best offer yet if you're not happy
with your results after 90 days
hymns will give you a full refund right
now my listeners can get their first
visit absolutely free
go to fourhyms.com ben that is for
hims.com
ben prescription products require an
online consultation with a health care
provider who will determine if the
prescription is appropriate restrictions
applies to your website for details and
important safety information
remember that is for hymns dot com slash
ben alrighty we're gonna get to much
more in just a second
including the biden administration now
announcing that they will allow you a
dollop
just a dollop of freedom if you have
gotten a vaccination
first last november we made a major
announcement we announced
the one and only candice owens would be
joining the daily wire family with a
brand new show well folks
the long wait is finally over i'm
thrilled to announce daily wire's newest
show candice
will be premiering next friday march
19th next friday
okay it's coming up very fast no one
triggers the left quite like candace
whether she is slamming harry styles for
wearing a dress or getting into a
twitter war with cardi b
many have tried to cancel candace all
have failed
and i've known candace for quite a while
and she's definitely a controversy
magnet in 2018
candace kicked off the blexit foundation
which aims to change the narrative that
surrounds america's minority communities
she's also the author of the new york
times bestseller blackout how black
america can make its second escape from
the democrat plantation
and get to know candace the real candice
every week you know not the caricature
the media want to create of candace as
she shares her humor her insight as she
defies the stereotypes
it starts next friday march 19th candace
will be exclusive
to daily wear members hey you got to be
a member if you aren't a member yet go
to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25
off that is dailywire.com subscribe use
code candace for 25
off again this is your reminder candace
owens has a brand new show only
only a daily wire and you can only
access it if you are a member we have so
much good stuff for our members right
now we have movies and we have kansas
city show we're going gonna have a movie
with gina we have like tons of stuff
coming for you become a member right now
dailywire.com subscribe use code kansas
and get 25
off you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
so what is in hr one what is in this
this massive
new voting bill that democrats are
pushing forward according to national
review
it would be an understatement to
describe h.r 1 as a radical assault on
american democracy federalism and free
speech
is actually several radical left-wing
wishlists stuffed into a single 791-page
sausage casing
it would override hundreds of state laws
governing the orderly conduct of
elections
federalized control of voting and
elections to a degree without precedent
in american history
and two centuries of state power to draw
congressional districts turn the federal
elections commission into a partisan
weapon
and massively burden political speech
against the government while offering
government handouts to congressional
campaigns and campus activists
merely to describe the village to damn
it and describing it is a herculean task
in itself
states have long experienced running
elections different states have taken
different approaches the federal
government traditionally intervened only
to prevent serious abuses of voting
rights
hr 1 would upend that balance for no
good reason wrecking carefully refines
state regimes for securing the vote it
also throws out much of the work of
federal election laws passed with
extensive
bipartisan support in 1993 and 2002.
the first target is wiping out state
laws that allow voters to be checked
against a pre-existing
list of registrations hr 1 mandates
states provide
same-day registration and allow people
to change their name and address on the
rolls at the polling place on election
day
then forbid states from treating their
votes as provisional ballots that can be
checked later
which is a recipe for massive voter
fraud it mandates online registration
without adequate safeguards against
hackers it mandates automatic rage
automated registration of people who
apply for unemployment medicaid
obamacare in college
or who are coming out of prison right so
basically anybody who's government
dependent
is going to be automatically registered
to vote which you can see why democrats
are pushing this
the bill's authors expect this to
register non-citizens they create a safe
harbor against prosecution of
non-citizens who report they have been
erroneously registered
state voter id laws are banned they're
replaced simply by a sworn voter
statement
the dramatic expansion of mail and
voting during covet is enshrined
permanently in federal law
states are banned from the most
elementary security methods for mail and
ballots they must provide a ballot to
everyone
without asking for id and may not
require notarization or witness to
signatures
states are compelled to permit ballot
harvesting so long as the harvesters are
not paid per ballot
so democrats can just pay per hour and
just go pick up a bunch of democrat
ballots
curbside voting ballot drop boxes 15
days early voting are mandated
nationwide the bill micromanages the
location and hours of polling stations
early voting locations
and drop boxes states must accept voter
registrations
from 16 year olds even though they can't
vote before turning 18.
the bill shifts the job of sending up
young voters to the federal government
which will pay to teach 12th graders how
to register
create a campus vote coordinator
position on college campuses and award
grants to colleges for demonstrated
excellence in registering students to
vote
restrictions on felon voting felon
voting and federal elections are
overridden
and hr one takes the drawing of
congressional districts out of the hands
of elected state legislatures who have
done the job since the founding and
turns them over to quote unquote
independent commissions
it also counts inmates as residents of
their last address even if they are
serving
a life sentence and there are crackdowns
on political speech
one provision could be read to bar
corporations from political activity if
they have a single foreign shareholder
new disclosure rules would treat huge
amounts of speech and advertising as if
they were campaign contributions
this would require donors to say the
aarp to be identified as supporters of
any candidate if the aarp demands the
candidate keep a promise
to protect social security 501c4s would
be required to disclose their donors
i mean it's a mess it's a complete mess
and this is what's being pushed forward
by the biden administration so moderate
so much unity you can see it happening
now if you get the feeling that these
folks just want to control your life in
pretty much every way and then rig the
system
so that they always win elections
through ballot harvesting
and through unverified ballots and make
it less
less trustworthy okay remember i am not
one of the people who thought that voter
fraud and regularity decided the 2020
election
in fact i spoke out against that idea i
didn't think the evidence was provided
i was willing to hear evidence if it was
provided there's not a lot of evidence
provided
okay i'm not one of the people who was
saying that
i don't trust results of elections i'm
saying i will not trust the results of
future elections if they are done under
the auspices of this garbage bill
it's gonna be very difficult to trust
elections when you are literally just
registering voters on the same day as
they change their names
and addresses and those ballots are not
counted as provisionals
if that alone is enough to undermine
voter integrity
and meanwhile our our masters of control
in the federal government
they are now deeming that you can have
at least a little bit a little bit of
freedom if you get vaccinated according
to the cdc
the vaccinated can get together in small
groups alone rachel wolenski
who is the the politically motivated
head of the cdc remember
she at one point said that teachers
didn't need to get be vaccinated in
order to get back to school
and then she was undercut by joe biden
right because don't worry this is the
administration of
science wolinski spells out the new cdc
standard with regard to vaccinations
if you and a friend or you and a family
member are both vaccinated
you can have dinner together wearing
masks without distancing
you can visit your grandparents if you
have been vaccinated
and they have been too cdc recommends
that fully vaccinated people
can visit with unvaccinated people from
one other household indoors
without wearing masks or physical
distancing as long as the
unvaccinated people and any unvaccinated
members of their household
are not at high risk for severe covet 19
disease
okay i mean this is it makes no sense
none of this makes any sense okay if the
cdc is saying that fully vaccinated
people can gather indoors with others
who are fully vaccinated in small groups
why in small groups why not in big
groups everyone's vaccinated
okay so there's that why is it that i
can get together in a small group
with a with with people who are
unvaccinated not knowing whether they
have coveted
if you're afraid that i'm going to give
them covet i shouldn't be getting
together with them at all because
they're unvaccinated
and if they are going to give me covet
then why should only be one household
none of this makes any sense the real
standard should be if you're vaccinated
you can go live your life
and we can all get back to normal that
should be the standard everybody knows
it
even folks on the left are recognizing
how nonsensical these standards are what
are they really designed to do what
they're really designed to do
is give the ability for teachers unions
to say even if our teachers are
vaccinated they can't be back in schools
that's really what this is about
because under these standards if
teachers are vaccinated they still can't
be back in schools
right teachers with a bunch of
unvaccinated students remember students
can't be vaccinated these
vaccines have not been cleared for kids
okay if
if teachers are in the school they are
by definition
now violating the rules of the cdc they
are in the presence
of multiple household members who are
unvaccinated which violates the cdc
standard
so even if teachers are vaccinated they
can't teach that is the purpose here
that is the ex
that is the implicit goal here even
cnn's medical analysts were like this
makes no sense
here was uh here is was leanna wen
making the case this is idiocy
this is one of these examples where i
think the cdc is being far
overly cautious in a way that defies
common sense
because look at what they're saying
about quarantine so they're saying that
if somebody
knowingly is exposed to an individual
with copa 19
and they're fully vaccinated they don't
need to test or get quarantined
if you're sitting on a plane you're not
necessarily sitting next to people with
kobe 19 you're wearing
a mask ideally you're keeping distanced
and so it does it just doesn't make
sense that
you can't travel especially if you now
can get together with loved ones
okay none of it makes any sense because
one of the cdc standards is you're not
supposed to travel either
so basically the cdc is just pulling
this directly out of their own rectum
that's all this is they're just pulling
it out of their their own butts
apparently
the original cdc standard said
vaccinated people can travel and then
apparently
the reason that there was a delay in the
cdc standards being released
is because the politicos the head of the
biden administration got involved and
decided to reset the standard don't
worry guys this is the party of science
all they care about is the science
that's all they care about
it's amazing meanwhile as i say the goal
here really is to keep teachers out of
schools
because the teachers unions don't want
to be back in schools how do we know
this well
here is the united teachers la president
sicily meyer cruz
openly stating that if you reopen
schools you are a racist
if you condition funding on the
reopening of schools
that money will only go to white
and wealthier schools that do not have
the transmission rates
that low income black and brown
communities do
this is a recipe for propagating
structural racism and it is deeply
unfair to the students we serve so in
other words we don't want to go back to
school
and if you condition funding on us going
back to school then everybody's going to
go to the wealthier private schools
yes they are which is why you should go
back to school
it's why you should go back to school
but again the biden administration is
just making excuses for their political
allies as
always this child tax credit routine is
designed
in order to shore up a voting base their
cdc standards are designed in order to
shore up a voting base
we are watching a radical redefinition
of the relationship between the
individual and government
is being done under the auspices of
covet even by the way as we are now
experiencing the slowest spread of covet
cases
since the pandemic began with the
broadest seating right just remember
a couple of months ago we were seeing
300 000 new cases every single day
diagnosed in the united states
and we know that for every diagnosed
case there are probably another four or
five cases minimum that were out there
it's probably a million new cases a day
of covid
were happening in the united states and
yet
now we are at the lowest rate ever and
biden is out there still talking as
though we're in crisis why
because crisis is opportunity crisis is
always opportunity for these people
according to according to the bloomberg
news with the us vaccination effort
picking up speed new coveted cases in
the us rose
1.5 percent in the weekend of sunday the
slowest increase since the pandemic
began
almost a year ago the u.s reported 420
000 infections for the week after
recording 471 000 cases in the prior
seven days according to data compiled by
johns hopkins university
and bloomberg the percentage gain was
the smallest since bloomberg began
tracking cases
in january of 2020. some of this is the
vaccinations a lot of this has hurt
immunity a lot of people have already
had coveted
many of those people are asymptomatic
this is why all the stupid headlines you
see about oh my god spring break they're
gonna party in florida yeah they did
last summer you know what happened
nothing
remember how tampa bay was going to turn
into a coveted hot spot after the super
bowl and it didn't
you know why because we are getting very
close to herd immunity in wide areas of
the united states
but this can never be admitted and so
the cdc which is a political tool of the
biden administration at this point
they're just going to keep saying that
you have socially distance and wear
masks because
again the point is not saving lives at
this point the point is to continue to
perpetuate a feeling of crisis that
requires massive government
interventionism that is the goal here
it is perfectly obvious from every
available angle so just recognize
that there that the democratic agenda
requires
it requires a facade either the facade
is a crisis that requires a wartime
mobilization or
the facade is a genial old man who can't
string together a paragraph
those are the facades because if you
ever got a gander at their actual policy
like boys or girls and girls are boys or
natural policy like
what if we just paid everybody to stay
home and not do anything
and also incentivize people not to keep
fathers in the home
or what if we just completely opened our
southern border if you actually got a
gander at those sorts of policies
you might start to doubt the policy so
instead follow along as joe biden eats
ice cream and look at his loving
relationship with his wife
the greatest doctor in the world dr jill
biden and also aren't we in the middle
of the world's worst crisis not on the
border where we actually have a crisis
but you know in terms of covet even
though we have the slowest spread since
the beginning of the pan now it's still
a crisis
they need the misdirection the
misdirection is that joe biden is a
moderate unifier and that we're in the
middle of a coveted crisis
neither of those things are true neither
of those those things are true
now here's the thing this does mean they
are reliant on the crisis so if you see
through it if you see the crisis is not
there
and that joe biden is not a moderate
unifier and also that joe biden is just
a facade for this stuff
then the entire facade collapses which
is what they are
most anxious to avoid already we'll be
back here later today for an additional
hour of content
coming up soon the matte wall show
airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021.
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check
out the show